And I think reflection is kind of a reflection of that. Is that the cold open right there? Yeah, it's a great talk, and I'm glad David got his free beer. Welcome to ADSP, the podcast, episode 201 201 recorded on September 26, 2024. My name is Connor and today with my co-host Ben, we recap CppCon 2024. All right, yeah, we can hop into things. I'm doing good. How are you doing? I'm all right. Yeah, last week was CppCon, which was cool. It's right here on my doorstep. I do like to get a hotel room for the week because the hallway track is what it's all about, right?
我想“反射”本身就是一种反射。这就是开场白吗？是的，这是一场很棒的演讲，我很高兴 David 拿到了他的免费啤酒。欢迎收听 ADSP 播客，第 201 期，录制于 2024 年 9 月 26 日。我是 Connor，今天和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起回顾 CppCon 2024。好的，我们可以开始了。我很好，你呢？我还行。是的，上周是 CppCon，很棒。就在我家门口。我确实喜欢在那周订个酒店房间，因为走廊里的交流才是精髓，对吧？
Yes. And Aurora is, I'm not sure how far it is from you, but it is in general from Denver, like a 30, 40 minute drive depending on traffic, correct? Give or take. Yeah. It's because it's out by the airport. I mean, so I'm technically on the same side of town. I'm in the northeast quadrant, but it's about 25 minutes from my house.
是的。Aurora 离你有多远我不确定，但从丹佛出发，根据交通情况，开车大概需要 30 到 40 分钟，对吧？差不多。是的，因为它在机场那边。我的意思是，从技术上讲，我在城市的同一侧。我在东北象限，但离我家大约 25 分钟路程。
Jason lives about halfway between my house and the hotel, the conference hotel. He's slightly closer. Okay. A little bit closer. So does he stay? I'm guessing he commutes from home because 12 minutes is a little bit more doable than 30. He does commute.
Jason 住在我家和酒店，也就是会议酒店的中间。他稍微近一点。好的。近一点点。那他住哪儿？我猜他是从家里通勤，因为 12 分钟比 30 分钟更容易实现。他确实是通勤。
One day he did the run. One day he, either Wednesday or Thursday, he decided to get up in the morning and run from his house to the Rockies. To the Gator of the Rockies. That's one way to do it. I guess then did he have to run home at the end of the day as well i don't know he might have got a lift with one of the other locals i don't know what he how what he did okay but it's about it's roughly a half marathon it's around from his house to the gator the rockies my guess is he didn't he didn't do 20k in the morning and then 20k
有一天他跑步去了。有一天，要么是周三要么是周四，他决定早上起床，从他家跑到落基山脉。跑到落基山脉的门口。那也是一种方式。我猜他最后还得跑回家吗？我不知道，他可能搭了其他当地人的顺风车，我不知道他是怎么做的。好的，但那大约是半程马拉松，从他家到落基山脉的门口。我猜他早上没跑 20 公里，然后……
at the end of the day i'm guessing he didn't run home because in the morning and then 20K at the end of the day. I'm guessing he didn't run home. Because that's a marathon. That's a CPPCon day sandwiched inside a marathon half on each side, which would be pretty intense. Anyway, so that is the topic of episode 201. I mean, people might be a little bit confused but they did get a teaser i think it was in episode 196 or something because bryce and i recorded for two or three and it was the one where we were at cpp north we teased that we might be replacing bryce and that's what we've done now
在一天结束时……我猜他没跑回家，因为那是马拉松。那相当于在马拉松中间夹了一整天的 CppCon，两边各半程，那会非常累人。总之，这就是第 201 期的话题。人们可能会有点困惑，但我想他们在第 196 期左右听到了预告，因为 Bryce 和我录制了两三期，那是我们在 Cpp North 的时候，我们预告说可能会替换 Bryce，现在我们已经这样做了。
at least for the short term we'll see how it goes we've got a new co-host. So, you know, we might keep Bryce's Twitter info and whatnot in the show notes, but we're going to have to add Ben's and we're doing our first topic, which is a CPPCon recap. You were there. I was not. I believe, were you speaking? I did. I had one scheduled talk on the main program and I did an open content session and I did a lightning talk. Okay. So maybe we'll start with recapping your talks and how they went, and then we can go into highlights from other talks and keynotes you saw.
至少短期内是这样，看看效果如何，我们有了新的联合主持人。所以，你知道，我们可能会在节目说明中保留 Bryce 的 Twitter 信息之类的，但我们得加上 Ben 的，我们正在进行第一个话题，也就是 CppCon 回顾。你在现场，我不在。我相信，你演讲了吗？是的。我在主日程上有一个预定的演讲，我还做了一个开放内容环节，还有一个闪电演讲。好的。那我们先回顾一下你的演讲情况，然后再谈谈你看到的其他演讲和主题演讲的亮点。
So my talk was the same one I gave in Toronto, message handling with Boolean algebra. I may have titled it message handling with Boolean implication at one point. It's the same talk basically. And it's about, you know, it's about the open source library, one of the open source libraries we have that I work on at Intel, which is whose job is message handling and matching messages that come off the notionally off the wire and dispatching them. You know, this is a topic that loads of people have in their code bases, right? This is a very common sort of problem to solve. We wanted to solve it in a very generic way.
我的演讲和在多伦多做的一样，是用布尔代数处理消息。我一度把它命名为“用布尔蕴含处理消息”。基本上是同一个演讲。它是关于我们 Intel 开源库中的一个，我参与了开发，它的工作是处理消息，匹配从网络上接收到的消息并进行分发。你知道，这是很多人在代码库中都会遇到的问题，对吧？这是一个非常普遍的问题。我们想用一种非常通用的方式来解决它。
And what came out of it was, I think, this really nice library where you know how sometimes when you're writing code, you just know things are composing well together. And that's because it's it's just boolean algebra under the hood but this talk suffered a bit from maybe a sort of lackluster abstract because people people see oh message handling with boolean algebra what's what's exciting about that you know this is something everyone does message handling everyone knows boolean algebra um but this talk had i think a really good pacing. It was baby steps, building and building and building. It's one of these talks where... Actually, I had someone tell me afterwards,
结果就是，我认为这是一个非常好的库，你知道有时候当你写代码时，你会感觉到事物组合得很好。那是因为底层其实就是布尔代数，但这个演讲的摘要可能有点平淡，因为人们看到“用布尔代数处理消息”，会觉得这有什么令人兴奋的？你知道，这是每个人都会做的事情，每个人都知道布尔代数。但我觉得这个演讲的节奏非常好。它是循序渐进的，不断构建。这是那种……实际上，之后有人告诉我，
they said that was a very approachable talk. They said I followed like 85%, 90% of it. There are some non-obvious things in the talk. And in particular, the use of implication, which people don't... It's hard to intuit as a human Boolean implication. It's one of these operations we don't use very often or at all, really. But I use it as a building block in the talk. So it was a talk I was very happy with. You know, I submitted. It's funny that the two talks I had this year, sort of that I made this year, were that one and the one about senders and receivers.
他们说那是一个非常平易近人的演讲。他们说我听懂了 85% 到 90%。演讲中确实有一些不那么显而易见的东西。特别是蕴含的使用，人们不……作为人类，很难直观地理解布尔蕴含。这是我们不常使用，或者根本不使用的操作之一。但我把它作为演讲的基石。所以我对这个演讲非常满意。你知道，我提交了。有趣的是，我今年做的两个演讲，就是那个和关于发送者与接收者的那个。
I submitted both to C++ Now earlier in the year. Of course they only picked one. From my point of view they picked the wrong one. They picked senders and receivers which is, you know, which was the new, is the new hotness and totally appropriate for C++ Now. Unfortunately that was the one I hadn't made yet when they picked it so I had to make that talk. But I'm glad I got to give the Boolean algebra message handling one, both in Toronto and just in Aurora. Nice. Now, we will leave show notes for all instances of those talks.
我今年早些时候都提交给了 C++ Now。当然，他们只选了一个。从我的角度看，他们选错了。他们选了发送者与接收者，那是新的热门话题，非常适合 C++ Now。不幸的是，当他们选中它时，我还没做出来，所以我不得不赶制那个演讲。但我很高兴能在多伦多和 Aurora 做了布尔代数消息处理的那个演讲。不错。我们会把这些演讲的所有实例留在节目说明中。
And I can definitely agree with the approachable part. part i think i recall when i watched it in toronto and uh at cpp north that it was up until the implication part that like everything i was following along and then you kind of made a statement and i was like i guess and i kind of like squinted and you know my eyes rolled up and i started thinking about it and i was like okay i can kind of see that but then like you walked through a couple different ways of looking at it and examples and then by the end of it i was like okay i completely understand now what he was saying and i definitely didn't the squinting of my eyes and like thinking that i understood it was like generous i did not and then after you walked through those couple examples it was like very clear uh so yeah i i can totally agree with that feedback that you got from someone
我绝对同意“平易近人”这一点。我想我记得在多伦多和 Cpp North 看的时候，直到蕴含部分之前，我都能跟上，然后你做了一个陈述，我就想“大概吧”，我眯起眼睛思考了一下，然后想“好吧，我大概能看懂”，但随后你通过几种不同的视角和例子进行了讲解，最后我完全理解了你在说什么。我之前眯着眼睛思考并以为自己懂了，其实是高估了自己，我并没有懂。但在你讲解了那几个例子之后，就非常清晰了。所以，我完全同意你从别人那里得到的反馈。
saying that it was approachable um and when the word algebra is in the title of a talk, you know, it's not always the case that it ends up being approachable. So. Right. Yes. Well, I'm anyway, I thought it went really well. And I'm happy with that talk. You know, perhaps you have the same thing as a speaker. Some of my talks, you know, the know the talks vary frankly some are on some are like when the topic comes together with a really good explanation and a really good you know and it just feels good other talks are more of a slog to get through maybe the timing's not quite right maybe you know different things go wrong with them when I give them, you know, and maybe it's only me, maybe it's only the speaker who notices because at the end of the day, the audience doesn't notice what you don't say, what you leave out or all those things you had in your head. Right. But I
说它平易近人。而且当演讲标题里有“代数”这个词时，你知道，它并不总是平易近人的。是的。好吧，总之，我觉得效果很好。我对那个演讲很满意。你知道，也许作为演讲者你也有同样的感受。我的一些演讲，坦率地说，有些演讲在主题与非常好的解释结合在一起时，感觉很好。其他演讲则比较吃力，也许时间安排不太对，也许在演讲时出了各种差错，你知道，也许只有我自己，也许只有演讲者自己能注意到，因为归根结底，观众不会注意到你没说的话，你遗漏的内容，或者你脑子里想的所有那些东西。对。但我
think this is a sort of a natural feeling as a, as a content creator of any kind, right. That there are always things you wish you could have highlighted said done differently but anyway this talk i thought was not one of it was one where i was very happy with it right overall yeah it's nice when that happens and definitely it's a true uh fact that as a speaker you have or at least i think most speakers that I've spoken to, they have like a vision and a picture and some amount of rehearsed-ness to what you're going to say. And then inevitably in most talks, not all of them, like it sounds like this one went pretty, pretty smooth and you said all you wanted to say, but every once in a while, or, you know, in half your talks, you'll forget to say something, or you said something a little
认为这作为任何类型的创作者都是一种自然的感觉，对吧？总有一些事情是你希望自己能强调、说出或做得不同的。但总之，我觉得这个演讲是我非常满意的一个。总的来说，是的，这种情况发生时感觉很好。而且作为一个演讲者，你确实有，或者至少我认为大多数我交谈过的演讲者都有一个愿景、画面和一定程度的排练。然后不可避免地，在大多数演讲中，并非全部，听起来这次进行得很顺利，你说了你想说的一切，但偶尔，或者在你一半的演讲中，你会忘记说某件事，或者说得有点
bit differently than you wanted. You will notice but like the audience right doesn't actually know what you wanted to say right so in your in your head or when you go back and re-watch it you'll be like i can't believe i forgot to say that but the listener or the watcher they're not thinking oh i wish he had said that thing yeah he or she didn't say they don't know that you wanted to say something else there so i think it's true that you're always a harsher critic uh watching your own talks than like someone else right because only you know the delta of what you really wanted the talk to be the listener viewer doesn't have that right anyway so you also said you did an open session and um yeah so the the open sessions are great like last year's open session last year i came to cp con i really enjoyed the open sessions are great. Like last year's open session, last year I came to C++Con
和你想要的不一样。你会注意到，但观众其实不知道你想说什么，对吧？所以你在脑海中或者回看时会想“我不敢相信我忘了说那个”，但听众或观众不会想“我希望他说了那个”。他们不知道你想说别的东西。所以我认为，作为自己的批评者，你总是比别人更严厉，这是真的，因为只有你知道你真正想让演讲达到的效果与实际之间的差距。听众或观众没有那个。总之，你还说你做了一个开放环节，而且……是的，开放环节很棒，就像去年我来 CppCon 时，我真的很喜欢开放环节。今年也是一样。这就像是“走廊交流 Plus”。我做了一个开放环节，和我去年做的非常相似，标题就是“杂项大杂烩”。
and I really enjoyed the open sessions. This year, same again. It's like hallway track plus plus. I gave an open session and I gave an open session that was very similar to my game last year, which was just like a grab bag of oddments was the title.
又一个杂项大杂烩。就是 C++ 的一些奇闻异事，奇怪的东西，可能有用也可能没用的东西，或者未来某天可能有用的东西。我认为玩耍真的很重要，对吧？这个演讲就是本着玩耍的精神。所以这两个演讲都没有被录制过。我在聚会之类的地方做过几次，但它们永远不会被录制。
Another grab bag of oddments. Just like oddities of C++, weird things, strange things, things that may be useful or may not be, or might be one day. I think it's really important just to play, right? And this talk is in the spirit of play. So neither talk has ever been recorded. I've given them a couple of times at meetups and things, but they're never going to be recorded.
但它们确实是互动环节，我展示代码片段。我说，“看，这是一些代码，这是一些代码，虽然不能编译，但如果能编译，我们会怎么想？”或者，“看，这是我发现的一个非常奇怪的东西。也许今天没用。但是，如果 C++ 教会了我什么，那就是今天我们嗤之以鼻、认为是一种糟糕技术的做法，明天就会成为广为接受的基石。”是的，是的。所以你给听众留了悬念，有没有幻灯片或 Godbolt 链接可以发出来，如果人们好奇的话？还是他们必须去 CppCon 或其他会议？
But they are really just interactive sessions where I present snippets of code. And I say, you know, here's some code, here's some code, which doesn't actually compile, but we might, if it did compile, what would we think? Or, you know, what, here's a really odd thing that I discovered. And maybe it's not useful today. But, you know, if C++ has taught me anything, it's that today's thing that we turn uh if c++ has taught me anything it's that is that today's thing that we turn our nose up at and think is a horrible technique is tomorrow's well accepted building block yes yes i mean so you've teased the listener is is there any form it doesn't sound like a slide deck or godbolt links that we can send you know one or two of them if uh people are curious or did they just have to come to CppCon or a different conference?
嗯，这是一个去参加会议或参加当地聚会的好理由。可能有幻灯片。我确实有幻灯片，并且把它们发到了 CppCon Discord 上。所以它们是半公开的。但我给你举一个奇闻的例子，好吗？所以……完美。我们知道，我想大多数听众现在可能都听说过那个古老的……
Well, it's a good reason to go to a conference or attend a local meetup, I would say. There may be slides out there. I did have slides and I posted the slides to the CppCon Discord. So they are semi-public. But I'll give you an example of one of the oddities here, right? So... Perfect. We're aware, and I think most of our listeners probably at this point have heard about the old,
数组索引技巧，你可以交换数组和索引，因为底层只是指针算术，而算术是可交换的，对吧？所以如果你说 A[3]，这和说 3[A] 是一样的。同样，因为底层数组退化为指针，它给指针加 3 来获取元素，对吧？指针加 3 和 3 加指针是一样的。对。这是已知的，对吧？在 C++ 奇闻的背景下，这并不是什么新鲜事，对吧？
the array indexing trick where you can swap the array and the index because it's just doing pointer arithmetic under the hood and arithmetic is commutative, right? So if you say A index of 3, that is the same thing as saying 3 index of A. Again, because under the hood, the array decays to a pointer, and it adds 3 to that pointer to get the element, right? And a pointer plus 3 is the same as 3 plus pointer. Right. This is known, right? This is not, in the context of C++ oddities, at least, This is not a new thing, right?
但一个有趣的事情是考虑如果你尝试索引一个数组，而你使用的索引是一个立即调用的 lambda 表达式会发生什么。好的，所以你有 A，左方括号，然后是你的 lambda 表达式，然后是右方括号。嗯，lambda 表达式以左方括号开头，然后是你的 lambda 表达式，然后是右方括号。嗯，lambda 表达式以左方括号开头。当编译器看到两个连续的左方括号时，它认为你正在开始一个属性，因为属性就是这样……
But one interesting thing is to consider what happens if you try and index an array and the index you're using is an immediately invoked lambda expression. Okay, so you have A, open square bracket, and then your lambda expression, and then close square bracket. Well, a lambda expression begins with an open square bracket, and then your lambda expression, and then close square bracket. Well, a lambda expression begins with an open square bracket. When the compiler sees two open square brackets in a row, it thinks you're starting an attribute, because that's how an
属性是两个标记。它不是一个标记，即双左方括号。在语法中，它实际上是两个单左方括号标记，而不是一个双左方括号标记，所以中间的任何空格都不重要。编译器不会让你用立即调用的 lambda 来索引 C 风格数组，除非你给它加上圆括号，或者除非你反转索引，即先写立即调用的 lambda，然后再索引数组。对。所以这可能是一个反转索引的现实用例。是的。对于那些试图使用立即调用 lambda 来进行索引的人来说。好的，是的，我绝对可以说我从未想过这一点。这就是整个演讲的精神。
attribute starts. And the attribute is two tokens. Then it's not one token, which is double square bracket. In the grammar, it's actually two tokens of single square not one token which is double square bracket in the grammar it's actually two tokens of single square bracket so any amount of white space in there doesn't matter the compiler will not let you index a c style array with an immediately invoke lambda unless you put parens around it perhaps or unless you flip the indexing, so you have the immediately invoked lambda first and then you index of the array. Right. So it's a real life use case, perhaps, for this reversed indexing. Yeah. For the people that are trying to use immediately invoked lambdas for the purposes of indexing. OK, yeah, I can definitely say i've never thought of that this is the whole spirit of
你知道，这完全是关于玩转语言，看看会发生什么。是的，我现在没有任何代码可以指出使用立即调用 lambda 来索引 C 风格数组的例子，但你知道，这是我现在口袋里的一个工具。这是一种可能性。它的精神几乎类似于你的“探索算法帝国”的累加，你弯曲算法，不一定是它们应该被弯曲的方式，但通过弯曲它们，你学到了一些东西，学会了在那种情况下更好地理解算法，但在这种情况下，是更好地理解语言。是的。主题演讲现在可以在网上找到，你可以在 YouTube 上找到它们，其中有两个主题演讲我觉得大家会非常感兴趣。Khalil Estelle 做了一个关于“用于小型固件的 C++ 异常”的主题演讲。
of the talk you know it's all about playing with the language seeing what happens and like yeah i don't have any code that i could point to right now that uses immediately about lambdas for in for indexing c style arrays but you know that's a tool that i have in my back pocket now. That's an, that's a possibility. It's, it's almost similar in spirit to your accumulate exploring an algorithmic empire where you bend algorithms, not necessarily how they should be bent, but by bending them, you learn some things and learn to understand in that case, the algorithms better, but in this case, like the language better. Yeah. The keynotes are up online right now you can find them on youtube and there were there were two keynotes in particular that i think will be very interesting to folks khalil estelle gave a keynote on c++ exceptions for smaller firmware
这是一个精彩的演讲，有很多数据，令人惊讶的内容，有很多硬核的测量，比如“异常到底要付出什么代价？”而且，你知道，他正在做让异常变得更好的工作，量化它们并更好地实现它们。其中有一些令人惊讶的结论，对吧？对一些人来说，甚至异常是嵌入式的一部分，或者可能是嵌入式的一部分，这都很令人惊讶。
this was a fantastic talk lots Lots of data, surprising stuff, lots of hard measurements of like, what do exceptions actually cost? And, you know, he's doing work, making exceptions better, quantifying them and implementing them better. And there are some surprising conclusions in there, right? It's surprising to some folks, even that exceptions are part of or maybe part of embedded.
它们在 freestanding 中是完全定义的，尽管我们知道大多数在该领域工作的人通常会关闭它们。但这个主题演讲，“用于小型固件的 C++ 异常”，确实让人大开眼界。所以是一个精彩的演讲。你说它们在网上。我自己看了 Herb 和 Daveed 的主题演讲，因为它们被发布到了 CPP 的 subreddit 上，但它们实际上是未列出的。我没看过 Khalil 的演讲。你知道那个也是吗？所以如果你是 Reddit 用户，你可能也看过这些演讲。
They're completely defined in freestanding, although we know that most people working in that space would typically turn them off. But this keynote, C++ exceptions for smaller firmware was a real eye opener. So fantastic talk. So you say they're online. I myself have watched both Herb's and Daveed's keynotes because they've been posted to the CPP subreddit, but they're actually unlisted. I haven't seen Khalil's talk. Do you know if that one was also? So if you are a Reddit goer, you may have also seen these talks.
我会确保找到那些未列出的链接，因为它们已经公开了。不是我，我不是第一个做的。而且我知道 CppCon，我想他们正在做某种你可以获得提前访问权限的事情。他们提供付费的提前访问，是的。好的，不，我实际上已经找到了，
I will make sure to find the unlisted links because they have been made public. It wasn't me. I didn't do it first. And I do know that CppCon is, I think they're doing some kind of thing where you can get like early access. They're offering paid early access, yes. Okay, no, I actually, I have found,
是第 43 号。我一定错过了这个。Khalil Estelle，“用于小型固件的 C++ 异常”。所以我想你提到的所有这些链接都会放在节目说明中，即使它们在 YouTube 上还没公开。嗯，我要推荐的另一个是 David 关于反射的闭幕主题演讲。在会议上，我必须说那是最后一场演讲。
it's the number 43. I must've missed this. Khalil Estelle, C++ exceptions for smaller firmware. So all of these links that I think you're about to mention will be linked in the show notes, even if they're not public on YouTube yet. Well, the other one I was going to recommend is David's closing keynote about reflection. And at the conference, I have to say that it was the very last talk.
而且如你所知，每个人都精疲力竭了。房间里的能量相当低。所以我认为这个演讲值得回去再看一遍，至少对我来说是这样，因为 David 展示了大量关于反射即将到来的令人兴奋的东西，不包括——著名地不包括——将枚举转换为字符串。Andre 在会议上对此有话要说，Andre Alexandrescu，你知道，我想他在某个时候说，“枚举转字符串差点毁了反射”。这似乎是每个人都想在昨天就得到解决方案的一件事，但它只是反射中极小极小的一部分，坦率地说，一点也不令人兴奋。
And as you know, like everyone is wiped out. The energy in the room is fairly low. So I think the talk is worth going back to and watching a second time at least for me because because david showed a ton of exciting stuff that's coming down the pipe with reflections not including famously not including converting an enum into a string andre had had words about that in the conference andre alexandrescu you know i think he said at one point point, enum to string almost killed reflection. It seems to be the one thing that everyone wants a solution to yesterday, but it is a tiny, tiny part of reflection and not very exciting at all, frankly.
但 David 的主题演讲展示了更多令人兴奋的东西。是的，你觉得不仅是演示，还有提案本身怎么样？我还没有详细研究它，但 Bryce 也说他在看到最后的代码注入示例后对此感到非常兴奋。是的。值得指出的是，反射的读取部分是一篇论文，而写入部分，或者说 introspection（内省）和 injection（注入）是两篇
But David's keynote shows many more exciting things. Yeah. What did you think of not just the presentation, but the proposal? I haven't gone through it in detail, but Bryce also says he's extremely excited about it after having seen the, I think it was the code injection examples at the end. Yeah. So it's worth pointing out that the read part of reflection is one paper and the write part or the, you know, the introspection and the injection are two
不同的论文。看起来我们将得到内省，我们也可能得到注入。但据我所知，其中一篇论文比另一篇进展得更远。426。好的。我会确保链接这两篇。因为我只浏览了 Reddit 的评论，但很多人说“这太棒了，我等不及了，我五年前就需要这个”。其他人则说，“这只会让 C++ 变得更加复杂”，我的意思是，在这一点上，C++ 并不是……
different papers. And it looks like we're going to get introspection and we may also get injection. But the one paper is further along than the other, as I understand it. 426. Okay. I'll make sure to link both of those. Because I only peruse the Reddit comments, but a lot of them were like, this is amazing. I can't wait. I needed this like five years ago. The other ones were saying, this is just going to complicate C++ even more, which I mean, at this point, it's not like C++.
我知道 Herb 总说它会变成一种简单的语言，或者简单 10 倍，但我不知道。我认为那艘船已经开走了。所以，嗯，我认为这是库与应用程序边界的问题，对吧？我认为应用程序端可能会变得简单得多，库端不会变得更简单，因为这实际上是 C++ 的座右铭，你知道，只要库提供给用户的 API 是干净、可组合且美观的，库内部任何程度的实现复杂性都是可以接受的，对吧？所以我们不会
I know Herb always says it's going to become a simple language or 10x simpler, but I don't know. I think that ship has kind of sailed. So, well, I think it's a question of the the library slash application boundary right i think the application side may get a lot simpler the library side it's not going to get simpler because it's practically c++'s motto that you know any amount of implementation implementation complexity in the library is acceptable as long as the API provided to the users of that library is clean and compositional and nice, right? So we don't
回避库内部实现的复杂性。我认为“反射”本身就是一种反射。这就是开场白吗？是的，我意识到我在句子中走上了那条路，但我没想出别的词，所以我就用了它。是的，这是一个很棒的演讲，如果你们去看了，我很高兴 David 拿到了他的免费啤酒。哦，对了。他谈到了 Andres 承诺给他的免费啤酒，
shy away from complexity of implementation inside libraries. And I think reflection is kind of a reflection of that. Is that the cold open right there? Yeah, I realized I was going down that path in the sentence, but I couldn't think of another word, so I just went with it. Yeah, it's a great talk, and I'm glad David got his free beer, if you do go and watch it. Oh, that's right. He talks about this free beer that Andres promised him
如果他不谈论枚举转字符串的话。在我们结束你的闪电演讲之前，还有其他你特别喜欢的非主题演讲吗？有几个关于发送者和并发的演讲。Dietmar Kuhl 展示了基于发送者和接收者的 HTTP 服务器创建。Ian Peterson 和 Jessica Wong 是 Meta 的两位优秀员工。
if he doesn't talk about the enum to string. Before we finish with your lightning talk, any other talks that were outside of keynotes that you especially liked? There were a few talks about senders and concurrency in general. So Dietmar Kuhl showed a senders and receivers-based HTTP server creation. Ian Peterson and Jessica Wong are two good folks at Meta.
他们展示了他们使用发送者和协程调试代码的版本。哦，哇。见到他们真的很酷。如你所知，我是 Intel 裸机发送者和接收者的实现者。所以能把名字和人对上号，见到 Ian 和 Jessica，感觉真好。Andreas Weiss 做了一个演讲，一个开放内容环节和一个主日程演讲，关于协程。
They presented their version of debugging code using senders and coroutines. Oh, wow. And it was really cool to meet them. As you might know, I'm an implementer of Intel's bare metal senders and receivers. So it was good to put faces to names, right? And meet Ian and Jessica in particular. Andreas Weiss gave a talk, an open content session and a main schedule talk about coroutines.
如果有人需要协程的基础知识，需要对技术方面进行介绍以便理解它们，我推荐 Andreas 的演讲。然后 Michael Case，我的好朋友和同事，做了他的演讲，题目是“用于驯服嵌入式设备并发的发送者模式”。那是一个很棒的演讲。Michael 和我在他演讲的前一天还在处理他的演示。而且，那是一个非常好的演讲。所以正如标题所说，使用发送者，
If anyone needs a grounding in coroutines, an introduction to the technical aspects so that they understand them. I'd recommend Andreas's talks. And then Michael Case, my good friend and colleague, gave his talk about, it was called Sender Patterns to Wrangle Concurrency in Embedded Devices. That was a great talk. Michael and I were working on his demo up to and including the day before his talk. And, uh, it was a really good talk. So using senders as the title says,
使用发送者来驯服嵌入式并发。太棒了。我会把所有这些演讲都放在节目说明中，但诚然，我不认为除了主题演讲之外的任何演讲会立即有链接，但随着它们在网上可用，如果人们想要，
using senders to wrangle concurrency and embedded. Awesome. I will put all of those talks in the show notes, but admittedly, I don't think any of them outside of the keynotes will be linked immediately, but as they do become available online, uh, if people want,
他们可以回来查看，因为通常这些会议现在发布得比较慢，我想还需要几周时间它们才会可用，至少还要一周。最早也要到 10 月初，对于付费的提前访问也是如此。最后但同样重要的是，你的闪电演讲，我假设仍然是五分钟。闪电演讲总是好坏参半，你知道，有些很有趣，有些非常技术性，有些是库或公司的广告。在今年我认为脱颖而出的演讲中……Cassio Neri，我那个偶然的日历极客朋友，做了几个关于日期和星期几之间快速转换的闪电演讲，即快速计算星期几，
they can check back, uh, because usually usually conferences these days they roll them out slowly uh and it's going to be another couple of weeks i think before they're even available at least another week they won't they won't be out till beginning of october at the earliest for the uh for the for the paid early access even and last but not least your lightning talk i assume there's still five minutes lightning talks are always a mixed bag you know some they're always the some are funny some are very technical some are advertisements for libraries or companies among the ones i thought stood out this year um cassio neri my my accidental calendar geek friend gave a couple of lightning talks about a fast conversion between a date and a weekday so computing the weekday quickly
这真的很酷。这是一个技巧，依赖于除以 7 是计算星期几的基础，对吧？对。但 7 比 8 小 1。而 8 是八进制的基数，对吧？这基本上是伪装的二进制。所以如果你想一想，那么在十进制中，正如我们人类所想的那样，相当于考虑除以 9。你可以玩一些技巧来做到这一点。所以你也可以玩一些技巧来除以 7，
which which was really cool uh and it's a it's a it's a trick that relies so dividing by seven is the basis of computing a weekday right right? Right. But seven is one less than eight. And eight is the base of octal, right? Which is basically binary in disguise. So if you think about it, so the equivalent in decimal, as we humans think, is thinking about dividing by nine. And there are tricks you can play to do that. And so there are also tricks you can play divided by seven
在八进制系统或二进制系统中，对吧？Cassio 有一个很好的方法，只需要几条指令。归结起来只需要几条指令就可以计算星期几，基本上就是乘法和移位。有趣。好的。把它加到列表中。Braden Ganetsky 做了一个演讲，他在 C++ Now 上也做过，关于……这是一个有趣的演讲，叫 BrainPlus，是他解析器组合子库的语法糖。值得一看。然后是几位我想点名的新演讲者，因为新人参与闪电演讲总是好事，因为你知道，这有时会带来主演讲。所以来自我当地聚会的一位成员 Emily Jury Johnson 做了一个演讲，“像生命依赖于它一样编码”，她在美敦力工作。在会议上见到她真是太好了，而且像我说的，她也在我当地的聚会中。那是一个非常有趣的演讲。然后
in an octal system or a binary system, right? And Casio has a nice, very, just a couple of instructions. It boils down to just a couple of instructions to compute a weekday and multiplying the shift basically. Interesting. Okay. Well, add that to the list. Braden Ganetsky gave a talk, which he'd given at C++ Now, about – it was a funny talk called BrainPlus, which is a syntactic sugaring of his parser combinator library. That's worth a watch. And then a couple of new speakers who I want to call out because new people getting into Lightning Talk is always good because, because you know it leads to main talks sometimes so one of the folks from my local meetup emily jury johnson gave a talk coding like your life depends on it she works at medtronic um it was great to meet her at the at the conference and and like i say she's at my local meetup as well that was a really interesting talk and then
Alex Man 做了一个关于她被指导经历的演讲。她的演讲叫“仅仅是摘要，一段受教者的冒险”。她的幻灯片很棒。我想她是用的 Canva 做的。我之前没听说过。哦，是的。但你可能听说过。我想那是一个基于 Web 的东西。
alex man gave a talk about her experiences being mentored. Her talk was called Just the Cliff Notes, A Mentee Adventure. And her slides were great. She had made them on, I think it's called Canva. I hadn't heard of it before. Oh, yeah. But you may have. It's a web-based thing, I think.
是的，是的。Alex，幻灯片质量很高。那你的闪电演讲呢？我的闪电演讲？我现在忘了是什么了。哦，Alex。那你的闪电演讲呢？我的闪电演讲？我现在忘了是什么了。哦，对了。不，我想起来了。我的闪电演讲不是关于 C++ 的。
Yeah, yeah. Very high quality slides there, Alex. And how about your lightning talk? My lightning talk? I forgot what it was now. Oh, Alex. And how about your lightning talk? My lightning talk? I forgot what it was now. Oh, right. No, I remember. My lightning talk was not about C++.
嗯，我只是稍微转了一下。它是关于加密填字游戏的。所以我做了那个填字游戏。我在会议前夕发了一个链接给你。你可能看了，也可能没看。会议前一周，我在半夜醒来，大脑沸腾，只想把东西从脑子里清出来。我最终做了一个 C++ 主题的填字游戏。我找到了一个托管这些东西的网站。
Well, I only turned gently. It was about cryptic crosswords. So I made that crossword. I sent you a link to it just before the conference. You may or may not have looked at it. The week before the conference, I woke up in the middle of the night with a seething brain wanting to just have to get things out of my head. And I made end up making a crossword C++ themed. I found a site that hosts these things.
叫 crosshair，像兔子毛一样的 crosshair.org。是的。我找了几个朋友测试了一下。感谢 Scott 和 Tristan。Tristan Brindle，我们的朋友，是一个加密填字游戏爱好者。总之，我的闪电演讲是对它的介绍，让人们知道它，发布这个 C++ 主题的谜题，让想找点乐子的人试一试。对于那些以前没见过这些填字游戏的人来说，它们至少可以说是深奥难懂的。
It's called crosshair, like hair like rabbit, crosshair.org. Yeah. And I got a couple of my friends to test it. Thanks to Scott and Tristan. Tristan Brindle, friend of ours, is a bit of a cryptic crossword aficionado. So anyway, my lightning talk was an introduction to that, making people aware of it, putting out this kind of C++-themed puzzle for people to have a go at if they wanted to have some fun. To the people who haven't met these crosswords before, they are impenetrable, to say the least.
但它们很有趣。之后或第二天有人来找我说，你知道，他们早餐时和同事一起试了试，成功答对了几道题。好吧，也许未来的一期节目会是我，因为我还没看。我确实看了节目说明中的一分钟加密链接。好的。我想我试的那两三道题都失败了。但也许……我确实看了节目说明中的一分钟加密链接。好的。我想我试的那两三道题都失败了，但也许我会试一试。我会看看我能走多远。然后我们可以一起过一遍。
But they are fun. I had people come up to me afterwards or the next day say, you know, they tried it over breakfast with some colleagues and they'd managed to get a couple of answers. Well, maybe a future episode will be me, because I have not looked at it. I did look at the one minute cryptic link in the show notes. Okay. And I think I failed to do the two or three that I tried. But maybe not looked at it. I did look at the one minute cryptic link in the show notes. Okay. And I think I failed to do the two or three that I tried, but maybe I'll do it. I'll see how far I get. And then we can walk through.
所以未来的一期节目，Ben 和我一起过一遍谜题的答案。所以去试着在下期节目之前完成它，我会说下四五期吧。我们会在未来的一期节目中做这个。好的。我想我们得跳过去了。所以节目说明中有所有闪电演讲和完整演讲的链接，我们要进入下一次录制了。
So a future episode, Ben and I walk through solutions to the puzzle. So go ahead and try and complete it before, I'll say the next four or five. And we'll do that on a future episode. All right. I think we have to hop over. So link in the show notes for all the lightning talks and full talks. four or five and we'll do that on a future episode. All right. I think we have to hop over. So Lincoln, the show notes for all the lightning talks and full talks, and we're going to hop into our next recording.
酷。一定要查看这些节目说明，无论是在你的播客应用中，还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天节目中提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个可以留下想法、评论和问题的 GitHub 讨论链接。感谢收听。
Cool. Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP, the podcast.com for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening.
希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反 Bryce。这一期还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。
We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-Brice. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
希望您喜欢本期节目，祝您有愉快的一天。我是反布里斯。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。